mark wells is hoping things are
beginning to get back to something
approaching normal
he runs an estate agency in london since
physical house viewings restarted last
week after a long lockdown
mark's arranged a steady stream of
visits to this property
and he says business is surprisingly
brisk
we opened our doors less than a week ago
and
you know flat we had 10 viewings
multiple bids on it's just gone under
offer very close to the asking price
another property just
just looks like it's going to go under
offer at the asking price just under a
million pounds
but that optimism is far from universal
between march and april applications for
home loans fell by more than 50 per cent
and there's still huge uncertainty about
the economy and job losses
now the center for economics and
business is predicting uk
house prices will fall by as much as 13
this year
a lot of people are very worried about
their jobs and they don't want to take
on big commitments when they're worried
about their jobs
they think that if they lose their job
and get a different job
they may be paid less and the
combination of these things means that
the amount of money people are prepared
to spend on housing
we think going out into the future is
noticeably less
than it was previously the pandemic's
also having a huge effect on commercial
property
one company into which owns huge malls
like this in britain
has suffered a slump in rental payments
as many shops shut down
now it wants extra time to pay back its
own debts
while in the u.s one survey said that in
april shopping malls collected only 28
percent of rents
and then there's the question of office
space social media giant twitter based
in this building
have told their employees they can
return to work once offices reopen but
if they choose to
they can stay working from home forever
and google and facebook have told their
staff they can stay working at home
until the end of the year so what does
this all tell us about the demand for
office space in future
you should look at the how volatility
your employee number is
the job natures and also your space
densities
average space per desk and most
important part in asia
is our average home size average home
size could potentially very small
and whether you have the internet and
utility to support the working from home
again it's a big question mark so
nobody's predicting the end of the
office
but with millions of people working
remotely and with more people relying on
shopping online than ever before
these are uncertain times for everyone
including real estate investors
nadine barber al jazeera london